大家好,我是蚂蚁蜜算的潘无穷
今天非常高兴有机会跟大家深入探讨一下秘材计算技术体系
经过我们这两年的观察和分析
我们发现安全已经成为数据要素流通领域的一个关键性因素
只有解决安全问题
数据提供方才能放心的把数据给出来
然后整个数据要素流通的整体风险才会被控制住
然后那些高价值高敏感高利润的场景才能真正的这个有限出来
这也是我们为什么认为数据要素流通最终一定会走向密调流通
今天除了把这些关键的思考跟大家分享一下之外
还会重点把密调计算技术体系进行一个展开的介绍
从介绍当中大家可以看出密调计算体系
它不是一个面向数据要素流通
有一个环节的单点技术
而是一个字体向上的
然后贯穿数据流通所有环节的一个综合的一个技术
这个是本次介绍的一个目录
首先会介绍一下外宣环的事情
整个数据要素流通
它的最主要的形式其实是数据外宣环
然后此时安全威胁发生了本质的变化
在安全威胁发生本质变化的情况下
密调计算就是一个必然的选择
然后介绍一下密调计算跟椰子保护计算的一个区别
椰子保护计算它其实是相当于一个技术内核的一个作用
它主要提供核心的安全能力
但是密调计算把它升级成一个面向产业应用的综合的技术体系
然后介绍一下密调计算的整个的体系结构
分层次分模块对密调计算进行一个展开介绍
第五部分对未来进行一个展望
下面介绍第一部分
首先介绍一下什么是数据要素
数据大家经常说
这个原有的信息系统也有数据
为什么就数据原来不叫数据要素
后来升为数据要素呢
主要还是整个对价值的一个认知的一个变化
原来的信息系统我们其实认为是以业无目标为导向
每个组件其实是一个流程
或者是完成业无目标的一个功能
在数据要素领域是以数据的价值释放为导向
每个组件是数据生命周期的一个环节
这样一个形式
我们可以看到整个信息系统的结构形式其实发生了巨大的变化
我们认为与之匹配的情况下
我们整个信息系统的设计的思维
整个信息系统的结构其实都应该发生分之性的变化
这里边写了一个问号
希望听完之后可以在自己心目中能够想象一下
在数据要素流通领域信息系统的核心支撑技术应该都有哪些
然后数据要素流通它的主要形式是数据外区换
这句话什么意思呢
左边那个图我展示的是数据内区换
在数据内区换中
数据主要是在一个机构主体内的一些区换
那可能也有数据中团
然后给每个业务系统提供数据
在数据外区换的情况下
数据其实是不同的机构进行合作的
那可能有的机构提供数据
有的机构加购数据
有的机构使用数据
为什么数据一定会走向数据外区换的
是因为数据生态要素
可其他生态要素其实有显著的不同
数据它在使用过程中不被消耗
即使是多个主体多轮子反复使用数据
数据也不会被消耗掉
那这种情况下
就导致数据可以被各个常点
各个地方去使用
然后数据本身它在不同的场景下
同一份数据在不同的场景下
它也会产生不同的作用价值
即便是同一个场景
只要数据越多也能产生更多的价值
所以这些特性也决定的数据要素
出现会走向外区换
那走向外区换之后
有一个非常非常显著的变化就发生了
数据外区换的情况下
这个安全威胁跟原来的数据内区换
其实是有本质不同的
因为外区换中的数据
它可能脱离原来持有方的管控边界
进到一个新的系统里
这个新的系统系统的运萎方
也就是管理员员
它可能跟原来持有方
就完全不是同一方
在系统建设当中
运萎方通常是一个权力中枢的位置
如果新的运萎方它主动作恶的话
带来的影响是颠覆性的
什么叫颠覆性的呢
就是说我们对安全措施进行一些增强
这种增强或者是
我们常见的原有的安全措施
基本都没法比地狱的
这种情况下
其实给我们带来一个咱们性的后果
数据提供方它具怕这种安全危险
它不愿意对外提供数据
然后从这个数据要素行业上来说
也会有这样的问题
就是因为没有加工者
数据加工者碰不到数据
所以大部分数据
可能是在处于缺乏加工的远矿的状态
然后多个参议方谁都不愿意把数据发给其他方
那么多方的数据其实没有办法进行融合计算
还有就是在数据没有办法对外提供的情况下
应用场景方其实也没有办法
对数据的价值进行验证
他也不知道我到底该不该启动这次数据要素流通
前面我们介绍了安全威胁
其实发生了本质变化
为了应对安全威胁
我们其实不是说直接入手一些方案
首先我们要在技术理念上进行一个变化
然后通过技术理念来指导
和延连我们后续的方案的设计
技术理念上我们主要是要进行以下的一些变化
一个就是我们要从主体信任走向技术信任
这个说的什么意思呢
就是我们不再依赖数据介入方
它人的城市可好
不再依赖数据方这个主体
它不会作恶
不会主动去窃取数据
而是说数据提供的话
能够通过技术保证自己的数据
不会被任何人窃取
为什么这么说呢
是因为主体信任能够连接的参与方是有限的
基于主体信任最后就会形成一个数据局域
在局域网之间相互不同
这个其实跟我们要数据进行管换流通的整体目的
其实是相配的
第二个就是管理特权要走向管理平权
这个说的什么意思
就是说整个数据流通的服务听方
服务听方它其实跟其他的参与方的权力应该是对等的
它不应该有能力
通过这个攻击或者是本身拥有权力这样的手段
去查看其他参与方的数据
只有这种平等的权力关系
才能让各个参与方愿意提供数据
那最后一个是从外国安全走向内生安全
这个说的是安全服务
它不应该是跟现有的系统这样独立建设的
然后以被调用的方式提成在现有的系统
这种方式它其实防不了运萎管理员
因为运萎管理员可以篡改这个调用关系
或者直接攻击这个原有的业务系统本身
那最后一定要走向内生安全
所谓的内生安全就是安全机制
它内置在每一个系统组件当中
并且对系统组件进行一个贴市的防护
在外区运环情况下
为了抵御来自这种具有特权能力的运萎管理员的威胁
最终数据一定是走向密谈
只有密谈才能防止任何人窃取或者滥用数据
这也是一个密谈的定义
国家数据局也给了密谈计算的官方的定义
简单来理解
其实密谈就是数据会出于任何人都没办法窃取或者滥用的状态
无论是通过密码学的方式保证的
还是通过可信信件的方式保证的
只要你能够达到任何人都没办法窃取或滥用
都叫做个密谈
下面把密谈做一些更加形象化的一个描述
一个就是数据的所有权力
其实仍然还在数据提供方这里
将来谁能使用数据
数据授权的发出都是数据提供方发出的
然后数据在整个流通中保证全连录密谈
数据不会被泄漏
然后全流程可信管控
保障数据不会被滥用
它这两个保障的强度要达到能够抵于越远方空击
为什么讲这个意思
就是说我们常见的这种加密
防温控制系统其实都达不到这个强度
我们必须通过新技术提升级
才能达到这个强度
然后下面我还写了一点讲提结构的事情
它最后这个结构肯定是多个组建协作完成
这样主要是满足现在大型系统里边的多个组建协作
我就可以让整个功能更为的复杂
然后并且具备这种弹性扩展的能力
这样通过弹性困难
将来我可以在性能上也可以支持大规模的计算能力
谈到密材计算的时候
很多人都关心密材计算
你现在到底成本是怎么样的
现在整个成本其实低于1.5倍
这个也要讲一下
过去行业其实存在一个误解的
当时因为硬件技术不常数
所以隐子保护计算主要是用一些纯密码学方案
这些方案其实是一般性能比较低的
百倍或者千倍的性能开销
大家长期以来就认为隐子保护计算
其实是一个比较开销比较大的一个计算
但实际上随着这个硬件的常数
现在这个计算成为降到名位分布式的1.5倍
对于一些计算密集性的任务
整个的成本可以降到1.1倍一倍
这个实际上已经远远低于数据流通带来的价值
它不会成为数据流通的阻碍
也就是说按照现在密台计算的成本
它其实已经可以让整个数据流通
都进行普遍性的覆盖
让人人都享受到高安全的好处
下面我们通过各个技术点的区别
从这个角度来说
让大家更详细的理解一下什么是密台计算
一个就是这种纯密码学的方案
这里展示了一下纯密码学的方案
大家可以看到
它其实有很多计算和网络交付
最终其实整个性能是受限的
实际使用过程中为了加速计算过程
它可能还会采用一些优化的方式
然后最终导致它有一部分结果
其实是以明文形式进行交付的
所以有的时候也会有一些安全问题
下面讲一下跟杀箱的区别
杀箱其实也输掉住流通里边常用的术语
但是大家觉得把程序放在杀箱里
然后这个程序就受到了保护
这其实是一个旺文生意的一个误解
杀箱它最初其实是为了防止恶意程序逃逸
什么叫做逃逸呢
就是防止恶意程序攻击宿主军
这个是用在什么地方呢
比如说沙漏软件
看到了一个疑似的程序
它把它放在杀箱里运行
万一这个程序是恶意的呢
它不会影响到宿主军里边
它在杀箱里边就可以对它进行一个运行
进行一个检测
这样一个安全能力
那么可以看到这个安全能力跟密台算
跟我们数据要素领域要的安全防御目标是接待相反的
对吧
这个数据要素领域要的安全目标是防止
这个管理员溃碳的一个科学业用
但是这个杀箱呢
它只是防止的应用程序
这个攻击宿主机管理员
依然是可以看到这个杀箱里面的程序的
然后与区块链的区别
区块链呀
数据要素领流通领域长提到的技术
那数据要区块链它是干什么
它其实是一个区中新化的共识机制
通过区中新化的共识机制
实现这个列上的数据不可篡改
但是它共识的过程中啊
其实是需要把这个名文进行广播
然后每个参与方进行相同的计算
结果相同的我就放到链上
结果不同的我就被作为一场就拒绝掉了
在这个广播的过程中
实际上这个各个参与方
它就已经拿到了数据的名文
这个其实是也没有达到我们说
这个外循环当中啊
我让这个数据不被其他人看见这个目标
这个区块链它也不是做这个事情
对下面我重点介绍一下
密探计算和隐私保护计算的区别
这个也是历次讨论当中
被问到最多的一点啊
从T1到密探计算
其实是从技术内核走向
符向符合产业应用的
综合技术体系的一个过程
这怎么看的呢
T1它其实只是CPU的一个原子能力
你可以认为它这CPU的一些指定级
它仅提供了最基础的隔离认证能力
那从CPU指定级到整个产业化应用
其实还需要很多很多
其他的体系化能力的构建
这就好比说我们有了金库和运烧车
它可以提供最基础的隔离能力
但是我想构建银行系统
那我还需要很多体系化能力
我有了汽车和火车
对吧 我有了最基础的运输能力
那我想构建运输系统
我还有很多这个体系化能力要构建
如果有懂这个计算机编程啊
那其实还有个更贴切的例子
就说这个西语啊
它理论上能够实现所有的逻辑
但是让用它来实现大规模复杂任务的时候
因为西语员提供的能力过于远走
导致基于西语员
就构建大规模复杂任务的时候
它整个任务经常会出现这个安全性问题啊
或者是过于复杂无法维护啊
或者是问题问题啊等等各种各样的问题
最后我们提出了面向对象员
把这些接种能力封装成类
封装成方法
最后才解决到这个问题
从提议到密台计算也是一样的道理
提议提供的能力过于的原子化
那你当解决中小规模的问题其实是没有问题的
当你解决像书教书流通这种大规模的问题的时候
提议就会出现这个安全性啊
或者是系统复杂性啊
支撑不了啊
或者规模支撑不了等等一系列问题
那大家可能会想啊
就是说你密台计算是一个世界
明文计算是一个世界
我是把明文计算的那些信息和体系
拿过来
然后把每个组件都放到提议里边
把它变成密台组件
是不是整个信息系统就变成了密台信息系统呢
这个是不是这样的
也就是说这为什么呢
就是在安全威胁发生险重变化的时候
不是这个单组件变化能够解决的
你必须进行整个体系性的一个变化
这里举个例子
就是在明文世界里边对吧
我们可以认为就是说
传统信息系统对吧
他认为这个运文人员是可信的
主要是防控制外部攻击
这就好比战争的时候对吧
我在我方区域构建这个防游公式
防止敌人从外部打下来
这样的一个体系
那在数据外区换内的情况下呢
我们认为运文人员有可能做恶的
完全可能是恶意的
这就好比是你是在敌人占领的区域
开展地下工作
而此时你的这个工作的这个系统的这个
组织形式啊
或者信息传统的形式啊
其实都跟你原来在自己方开展工作的时候
其实都是有这个显出变化的
前这个是从哲学层面去说啊
那你从这个具体层面来说
到底有哪些变化呢
这里举几个例子
比如说你这个运文人员不可信的时候
那原来有些事情是运文人员决定的
运文人员掌握这件事情的权利
那他不可信的时候这个是谁来做呢
比如说啊
这个应用之间的相互访问控制
对吧
这访问策略最初啊是运文人员去配置的
那运文人员不可信的时候谁来配这个事呢
那还有就是很多信息系统啊
是很多服务啊
他最初设计的时候都是有一个这个管理员
这个管理员其实是有这个高的权限
可以看到其他的这个这个人啊
或者是里边的一些关键数据的
比如说这个kms的管理员
其实可以导出命啊看到命啊
那你这个在这个密台计算体系下
这些事情怎么做
这些服务大概率是要重新构置的
重新重新构建的
不是说把它放到旗翼就可以的
应该要把它重新构建
对吧
让那个管理员没有这个超级权限
还有一点很容易被忽略啊
就传统信息系统中
很多逻辑关系我们在写程序的时候
其实默认他正确的
没有对他进行验证
你比如说你按照文件名是加载这个文件
我们默认就加载的是正确的
那你在密台计算体系下呢
这个就有可能被运用员员篡改
所以在密台计算体系下
所有的对应关系
所有的关系都要被找出来
然后都要进行严格的防护
并且这个防护程度要能够达到
抵于恶意管理员工具的程度
最后就是密台计算呢
他其实也是需要软件生态的
那这个软件生态不能另起炉灶
那这个整个成本和代价太大
必须兼容遗忧的生态
至少有两点
一个就是Linux生态
那你遗忧的Linux程序
要能在密台计算体系下运行下来
然后还有就是现有的一些这个
软件上面的生态
计算软件上的生态
比如说这些主流计算软件里面
那些脚本代码啊
这些代码要在密台计算体系下
也能够运行起来
下面我的整个密台计算体系
进行一个展示介绍
而左下角是密台计算体系
这个结构图
它主要分为五个部分
最下面的一个部分是可行机制
这个呢是让参议方
尤其是数据提供方
能够对密台计算体系进行一个度量
从而知道密台计算体系是什么样的
比如说原版是什么样的
为什么要知道这个事呢
这里边有个逻辑啊
就是你只有知道一个新系统是什么样的
你才能进一步判断
这个新系统的安全情况是什么样
可行机制就承担着这样一个作用
右边这个是密台底座
这个主要是提供密台的运行环境
以及数据密台的一个功能
再往上是数据互通层
这个呢主要是提供数据的全生命周期
互通流动的这个全生命周期的这个能力
包括这个管控能力
其中那个计算这个环节被单独提出来了
这是因为计算软件啊
它其实是非常丰富的
计算这个层面上
它其实有非常非常丰富的功能
所以这个地方单独作为一个层次
再往上呢那个是数据服务层
那这个呢就是以用户的视角啊
把这些功能啊组织起来
然后这个最终对用户提供服务
下面分层次去介绍一下
可行机制层他到底是怎么工作的呢
这里边有个核心是可行根
可行根呢他去度量这个所有的应用
然后以他为调量
权为机构就知道这些应用是好是坏了
然后对这些应用进行这个
颁发这个身份证书
然后继续身份证书参与方完成了
对整个这个可行应用体系的这个
这种度量和这个安全性的判断
那这里边前面说的这些安全目标啊
技术体理念怎么体现的呢
就是说这个
整个这个度量啊
它是依赖这个可行根完成的
然后这个参与方啊和可行根之间对吧
直接建立这种通信送到这个通道
这个中途任何人都没法串改
刚才说这个这个这个
这个度量验证的结果
这个就实现了这种技术信任
还有这个防护
这个可行根对这个可行应用的保护
是深入到每一个组建的
如果是我们大前信系统
我们叫微服
深入到每一个微服服的
所以才达到了内生安全的目标
可行根这个概念
为我们反复提起
为什么这个概念这么重要呢
就是因为正常情况下
一个主体啊
只信任在他自己本地运行的新系统
可行根啊
它是有一个自我防护能力的芯片
即使在远程啊
用户也可以对他进行信任
那那这样的话
就实现了用户
对远程信系统信任的一个零的突破
基于可行根为毛点
有可行根去度量整个这个主机系统
从而用户啊
能够知道远端主机系统的这个情况
然后再对这个这个这个情况
进行那个人工审核
那么他就会知道这个远端信息系统
是否安全
从而对远程系统进行信任
对
可行根在这个过程中
承担了一个关键的调量作用
下面我介绍一下这个可行应用身份
首先介绍一下可行应用
什么是可行应用呢
就是具备密探能力的应用
比如说T里边的应用
可行应用整个密探计算系统的一个基本组成单元
大型的密探计算系统
其实需要大量的可行应用相互协作
协作过程中可行应用相互之间
其实也有鉴别的诉求
但是这个鉴别诉求
不能单单依靠前面的这个远程度量来解决
因为可行应用它是一段长续
你即便通过度量获得了
另一个可行应用的原码
它其实没有办法进行人工审核
去判断原码是否安全的
这个时候我们就引入可行应用身份
我给每个可行应用颁发一个身份
可行应用通过身份就进行鉴别
完成前面的动作
这个看上去跟传统的身份颁发是一样的
但其实是不一样
传统的身份颁发当中
管理员在其中承担了中间人的工作
当然也可以通过这个亏探私药
或者提完工药进行操纵身份
可行应用身份颁发当中是全位机构
直接通过这个安全信道
直接把这个身份下滑到可行应用里
这样身份其实是任何人都不能操纵的
包括这个管理员 运用人员都是不能操纵的
它也是首个完全属于客观时期的身份
有了可行应用身份之后
就可以通过可行应用
就可以通过相互鉴别
连成一个更大的可行执行网络
用户只要验证一个可行应用
它就会知道这个可行应用
会继续去验证其他的可行应用
保证整个机序其实都是被验证的
在Metai体系下
很多服务其实都需要从构的
其中一个关键的服务就是MEAL服务
传统的KMS当中管理员是有特权的
它其实是可以导出MEAL
这样威胁到MEAL的安全
这在Metai体系下肯定是不允许的
在Metai体系下如果我们选择
让可行应用自己保存MEAL
因为可行应用它自己有硬件的隔离环境
它也可以保护MEAL的安全
但是一旦这个硬件损坏
这个MEAL可能就会永远丢失了
这在实际系统中肯定是不被允许的
因此我们需要构建一个新式的可行MEAL服务
这里可行MEAL服务里边
首先管理员是没有任何特权的
然后说的账号体系
就是用咱们前面说的可行应用账号体系
然后整体在可行体系下其实就是避缓的
然后通过可行MEAL服务
自身在通过硬件备份等等方式
来解决MEAL丢失的问题
然后减化可行应用用的负担
大家经常说区块链可以做日制的保护
但实际上区块链它没有办法保护
应用程序到上列过程中的安全
它只是说数据一旦上列之后
它可以进行保护
其实可行应用可以对日制进行更严谨的保护
它从日制产生之初就可以在可行应用之内
进行签名的保护
签名的MEAL是可行应用自己专属的
所以不会被外部的任何人员进行创改
整个的防范范围其实更大
安全运为
这个讲的是什么事情呢
就是说如果可行应用TGB里边
它里边有OS的话
整个的OS是需要进行改造的
那越远人员的很多权限是要被限制
以避免越远人员利用运为这个事情
来攻击整个系统
下面介绍一下密探底座层
密探底座层主要是为应用程序提供一个密探运行环境
以及实现数据的密探的能力
它从硬件隔离环境到应用的运行环境
主要还有哪些层次呢
一个是机密虚机层
这个主要是提供类似于虚运机的运行环境
在G上我们就可以跑OS
在OS这个层我们做的主要工作
就是对OS的安全性进行升级
然后在T上可以运行机密容器
在容器层主要是提供运员生的部署能力
再往上就可以运行可行应用了
在可行应用内部
我们要提供数据交囊的这种能力
然后让数据的权利路都符合数字合约的设定
有些同学可能并不理解可行执行环境的基本原理
这里对可行执行环境的基本原理进行一个补充介绍
可行执行环境的基本原理是CPU的一个功能
它在CPU上首先是加了一个加解密引擎
然后让所有进出CPU的数据都进行加密和解密
这样的话就可以保证CPU以外的任何硬件
比如说恶意的内存恶意的外设
其实都只能看到密文
它没有办法攻击数据
而且是硬件层面的
软件层面上就是前面讲的可行执行环境
同样也是基于可行根
然后让参与方能够远程对象进行度量
度量之后参与方就可以判断
可行执行环境里边的程序是不是好的
从而保证远间层面上没有任何的恶意程序
这里要补充一下
CPU的加解密引擎它其实是对外界的数据的完整性
也是有保护的
一旦远程度量了之后
这个度量之后被认为是好的数据和程序
是不能被更改的
安全性大概就这样了
无论是恶意的硬件或者是恶意的软件
都不能进行一个攻击
性能是什么个原因呢
就是说这个数据加解密的时候
它其实是跟内存访问同步完成
加解密并不耗费额外的CPU运转周期
所以它其实加解密引擎不会影响这个额外的性能
这个跟大家日常的认知可能是有些不太一样
这个主要是因为加解密引擎是做在一个CPU上的
就是我们俗话说的是做在ASIC上
就ASIC的加解密速度其实是非常非常快的
前面也介绍了主要是可静支音环境的基本原理
实际上可静支音环境的实践方式有很多种方式
左边展示的是信任根集成的CPU里面的
右边展示的是信任根和CPU用独立芯片去实现的
右边这个方式的好处就是说
这个信任根跟CPU厂商结偶
它不受这个CPU厂商的这个影响
并且可以由这个权威机构进行直接的一个管控
另外这种方式的时候的话
整个的这个可静支音环境可以适配任何主流的CPU平台
屏蔽这种硬件的差异
并且也可以屏蔽这个远程认证报告格式的这种差异性
T内的系统软件其实也经历过很多次迭代
然后不断的追寻性能和安全的最佳平衡点
最初T内里边其实主要是提供SDK
然后应用程序在使用这个T功能的时候
需要显示调用这个SDK的接口
之后是LiberOS这种形态
这种形态已经可以运行原生的Linux程序
然后LiberOS通过翻译和模拟
对上面提供Linux原生的这个环境
再往后就是说整个硬件层面
整个区域支音环境层面
就会提供区域的这种硬件接口
上面就可以运行原生的Linux
这样的话其实整个的兼容线和性能会最佳
但是需要对TOS的安全性进行一个改造和加强
下面给大家分享一下我们在TOS上的一个工作
如果属于编程语言的话
应该会知道C客机价价不是内存安全语言
因此基于C和C价价编写的大型程序
通常都会有安全漏洞
所以美国政府提议在2026年前将关键软件逐步
逐步摒弃这种C和C价价替换成这种安全的编程语言
但是这个作为最关键的这个软件Linux
其实是并没有启动这个事情
我们的清卵OS走在了美国的同行前面
我们首创了框内核架构
然后整体都是采用安全编程语言Rust的实现
在性能上可以披灭这种红内核架构
大家安全机器上可以披灭这个微内核架构
下面介绍一下密台交囊
密台交囊是怎么做到数据和使用策略进行绑定的呢
这个核心的原理其实是比较简单的
就是我们把数据和策略绑在一起
然后使用指定核心应用的公要进行加密
这样确保只有指定的核心应用
才能够获得这个数据和策略
然后数据提供方法在通过远程认证
检查这个核心应用的代码
然后看看核心应用是否会严格检查这个密台交囊
并且遵守密台交囊里的策略
密台交囊的逻辑看似这个非常的简单
但实际上这背后需要做非常多的检查
可信应用的拿到密台交囊之后
他必须做一个完善的检查
以避免可信应用被诱导做了一些非预期的运算
那一个完善的检查
他要能够构成一个完整的逻辑链
能够验证说最终进入计算的数据
算法什么都是符合预期的
在这个过程中至少要包含以下四个方面的验证
一个是提供者的真实性
就是说你数据是否是生命的参与方提供的
这句话什么意思呢
在这个图里面就是说这个数据二
它是不是就是A提供的
那这件事情不是默认成立的
必须要检查的
还有就是授权的合法性
就这个策略的签发的那个人
是不是这个真正的数据提供者
那会不会是别人对不对
造了一个这样的一个策略
还有就是请求的符合性
就是请求的内容跟数据上的策略是不是一致的
那最后还有一个这个加载的一致性
就是你最终加载今天的数据和算法
跟策略容标明的这个ID是不是一致的
这样说一下策略容一般只标明这个ID
比如说图中的数据二和算法二
这看似验证内容非常的多呀
好多内容大家觉得都很陌生
就因为传统的新系统一般只会验证第三点
从这里我们也看出密探计算体系
为了达到达成更高的安全目标
它实际上要验证的这个逻辑环节
比传统的这个新系统要多的多
并不简单是说我把全种的新系统
放到这个T里面就完成了
它其实整个的验证逻辑要改造很多
那这里我只是展示了一个最基础的势力
实际的系统可能比上图要复杂的多
里边的对应关系也要多的多
那这些对应关系其实都是要验证的
下面介绍一下数据互通层
数据互通层主要提供数据的全生的周期功能
前面讲的一个密探交档的时候
其实已经把这个数据的这种授权
法文控制这块已经介绍了
除了这外这个之外
还有很多其他的这个特色功能
我们在这里这个给大家重点介绍一下
首先是参与方身份
那这里要强调的就是说
那个有的信息系统啊
这参与方身份是这个数据服务方
的一个这个子系统颁发的
这种情况下其实是
不符合我们整个密探计算的这个安全要求的
因为如果是这边颁发的话
那它其实同时也可以在颁发的过程中进行作恶
在密探计算体系下
那个所有的用户的身份都是由权威方颁发的
那这样的话整个身份颁发的过程中
这个密探计算体系的这种
运萎人员管理人是没有办法作恶的
匿名化是个人信息保护的重要技术
在各宝法等很多法律中明确提出
对匿名化的一个要求
但是现有匿名化技术啊
主要是通过家造或者家有的方式来实现的
数据的主体信息还在
此时啊这个匿名化处理之后的数据
如果与开放空间的其他数据员进行比对
还是能够回复出来这个个人身份信息的
那缩空匿名化的思路呢是将数据
通过技术手段限制在特定空间里
然后切断这个数据呢
和这个开放空间其他数据员的关联的可能性
通过这种方式打向匿名化的
整个缩空匿名化技术我们可以看成
在这个缩空空间内
数据是可算不可迟的
所有的数据都是去标时之后才进入这个缩空空间的
在这个缩空空间外呢
数据又都是密吻的
根本不会进行那个加工运算
我们前面讲的这个密台计算的这个体系啊
和理论都是这个啊
按照这个核心原理去讲的
对吧
实际上背后的这个技术分支啊
非常的多
每个技术分支也有很多种实现方案
这个安全性啊不完全一致
而让用户能够去理解这个安全性啊
其实是非常复杂的
所以我们提出了个通用安全分级
这个在国际上也是首创
首次把不同的技术路线放在一起
进行同一分级
而我们是怎么实现的呢
这个大的原理其实很简单
就是我们通过这个
攻击防御的效果去分
这样就能够试验各种这个技术路线
那么把整个安全性其实分为五级啊
这个内容呢
其实也是国内的很多重量级的单位
都进行了参与
然后进行了很广泛的讨论
目前那个有白皮书发布
然后也在金可联盟呢
有送神的标准
第四层就是密探计算层
整个密探计算层啊
主要是将我们前面讲的
密探计算的这些能力
和以后的计算框架进行融合
融合之后能达到什么效果呢
就是说对下啊
我可以利用多个机构的数据
对上呢
我给这个使用方提供的接口呢
跟原有的这个计算框架
其实是一样的
这主要有两种这个实践方式啊
一种是类似于这种spark的这种实践方式
这个时候呢
是通过spark的拓展接口
然后在拓展接口里边引入这个
健全的能力啊
引入加密的能力啊
最后把这个能力呢
導向我们前面讲的这个
密探的这个互通层可信层和底座层
这样来实现的
那还有一种方式呢
是这种网关的模式
那这种呢
主要是在原有的这个密探数据固前面啊
加一个额外的网关
在网关层
完成对整个的这个健全啊
这样的一个工作
那这里要稍微补充一点啊
就说这个攻击者是不能绕过这个网关
直接调用这个密探数据固的
那这个呢
是通过前面我们讲的
这个可信层相互之间的健全来实现的
那再往后讲这个密探边缘框架
那这个指的是什么意思呢
就说如果我们把一个明文的逻辑
转成npc或者是这个he
那这个时候其实是有很多种选择的
然后需要逐个原子算子进行一个翻译
那这个时候我们可以给用户一个自动的
这个翻译的这个工具
他可以直接把这个啊
比如说这个基于ai原始框架的这个代码
然后自动翻译成这种密码学执行的这个代码
最后我们介绍一下这个密探数据服务场
就是说密探数据服务层主要包括以下几个服务
对首先是数据治理
在没有密探计算的时候啊
数据远方他可能有很多原始数据
他没有治理能力
他又不敢引入专业的这个数据治理人才
怕他们窃取数据
这个时候数据质量一直都是这个提升不上来
然后是整个产业的一个阻碍
那有了密探计算之后呢
他就不要这样担心了
他就可以引入专业的这个治理人员
完成这个数据的这个质量的一个提升
那加上探查指的是什么意思呢
就是我们有了密探计算
那么我可以在密探情况下进行数据价值探查
那这样的话
其实就不需要进行很复杂的这个前许审批
这样的话我们就可以以最快的速度
挖掘出越来越多的这个数据应用场景
数据产品研发除了前面我们说的功能之外
那么还会通过合成数据啊
或者是密探笔记本的方式啊
完阻止这个研发人员在研发的过程中切取数据
那最后我们对未来进行一个
我认为目前密探计算已经具备产业化落地的能力
并且在一些实际案例中初步展现了产业化实践的这个威力
但是背后深层次理论和体系啊
仍然需要大家共同的研究和探索
历史上很多伟大的产业都是理论和实践交替发展的
比如说1765年已经出现了改良的争计机
但是热力学其实到1824年才进行这个
提出理论的这个电机
然后飞机呢是在1903年这个就开始是非成功了
但是它其中它背后的理论要到1904年才会才提出
那我们认为现在密探计算就跟这些伟大的产业一样
以后其实也是这个实践和理论交替的一个发展
交替的一个促进
最后做一个总结
那数据要素它是一个新的产业
信任系统组织形式已经发生了这个巨大的变化
尤其是外循环安全威胁发生了本质的变化
导致遗忧的安全措施其实都失效了
那数据外循环这个技术体系的构建需要技术理念的一个变革
要走向技术新人管理平权和内生安全
那我从这个我们最初的这个隐私宝计算到密探计算
其实是从技术内核走向这个产业应用的综合技术体系的过程
整个密探计算体系是一个自己向上贯穿应用服务的全新的技术体系
在身份命药隔离硬件系统软件生态兼容等等方面进行了全面的技术创新
后面是我个人的一个联系方式
谢谢大家